[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOUIS PULLEN-FREILICH:
Hi, everyone.
I'm Louis, and I'm an engineer
on the Android Toolkit team.
Today, I'm going to be sharing
some best practices when
using the AndroidX Preference
library, part of Jetpack.
I'm going to be covering some
background behind Preferences
and try to clear up any
confusion between preferences
and shared preferences.
I'll demonstrate how to
build a settings screen
and some useful features
you can use along the way.
And I'm going to cover how
you can use multiple settings
screens, which is
especially useful if you're
migrating your existing
architecture to the AndroidX
library.
But first some background.
What are preferences?
The Preference
library is a framework
for building interactive
settings screens.
It handles building and updating
the UI, so all you need to do
is to find a list of settings
to be displayed to the user.
And it also handles interacting
with device storage,
so that any value that the user
changes will ultimately get
persisted to the device without
you having to worry about it.
Preferences itself currently
exists in two separate forms.
First, the Framework
Preference API.
This is being bundled
with the Android
framework since the
first version of Android,
so 11 years ago now.
Since it is part of the
framework, any new features
and bug fixes we add
only make their way
to the newer
versions of Android.
And given that the design has
changed a lot over the last 11
years as well, the Framework
API is themed differently,
depending on which
version of Android
the device is running on.
As a result of these,
we're no longer
maintaining the Framework API.
And instead, we recommend
using the AndroidX library.
The AndroidX Preference
library, previously known
as the v7 and v14 Preference
Support libraries,
is unbundled from the framework.
This means it can
be regularly updated
with any new features
and bug fixes we push.
The library itself is backwards
compatible down to API 14
and uses the same
updated material theme
across all your devices.
This results in a consistent
experience for your users.
And how does this all
relate to SharedPreferences
you may be wondering?
The shared preference
APIs allow you
to persist key-value pairs
of data to the device.
They're used internally
by the Preference library
to save and retrieve any
values that a user configures,
but aren't actually
part of the library
itself-- just a lower layer.
So let's start building
our settings screen.
We're going to start off by
loading the simple hierarchy
on the right.
We have a preference with a
switch that allows the user
to toggle state and a preference
that just displays text.
I'm going to cover how
you should structure
your architecture
and also some basic
attributes you should
be aware of when you're
using the Preference library.
So we're going to
start at the top
with a simple activity
that just acts
as a container for a hierarchy.
This should be an
AppCompatActivity
with an AppCompat-based theme.
The activity itself is
basically just a container
for this
PreferenceFragmentCompat, which
is the main entry point when
using the preference library.
All our interesting
preferences and configuration
will happen in here.
And this fragment itself
just wraps a hierarchy
of individual
preferences, which can
either be defined
in an XML resource
or defined programmatically
at runtime.
In this talk, we're
going to focus on XML.
So the activity itself is,
again, just a simple container
for our fragments.
So we just have some simple
fragment boilerplate,
and all we need
to do here is just
show our settings fragment.
The fragment, again,
fairly simple.
All you need to do is
overwrite this one method,
onCreatePreferences, and
then just setup the hierarchy
that you're going to inflate
and show to the user.
All the interesting definition
actually happens in the XML.
So this is our XML file.
We start with a root
PreferenceScreen object,
and this basically
is the main container
for the entire hierarchy.
Everything should
go inside of this,
and this should be
the root element.
Note that you should also place
your preference.xml resource
files in the res/xml directory.
So now we can add
our first preference.
This is a basic preference.
It doesn't have any
widget associated with it.
And we have these three
important attributes here.
The title and the summary
are the visual title
and the visual summary
actually displayed
to the user on the screen,
as you can see on the right.
And the key is pretty
important for two reasons.
Firstly, if this preference
were to persist any state
to the device, then
this is the key
that the SharedPreference
instance would use.
And also this key allows you to
interact with this preference
later on in your life cycle.
So it's very important
to declare a key
for every preference
in your hierarchy.
And now we can add a
SwitchPreferenceCompat.
This is a type of preference,
very similar to before,
but now we have a switch widget.
So whenever the user toggles to
the state of this preference,
this will update the
Boolean value persisted
to the key defined here.
Now that we've built
the simple hierarchy,
I'll show you some
other useful features
we can add to make
this even better.
Here's the hierarchy we're
going to end up with.
There's quite a lot
more going on here,
so we're going to
take it step by step.
First, I'm going to
cover Categories,
which allow you to
visually split up
a complex screen into groups
of similar preferences.
Then, preferences
that open dialogues,
which allow for more complex
configuration than just
a simple Boolean switch.
I'm going to talk a bit
about dynamic summaries
and also cover dependencies.
So continuing from where
we left off before--
these are the same
preferences I had before,
just without the root
PreferenceScreen tag,
for verbosity.
One of these controls
syncing and one
just displays static information
about the application.
Although, this is
kind of simple now--
there's only two things
in the hierarchy--
the more we add
to this hierarchy,
the harder it's going to be
for a user to actually see
what preference does what.
We can use preference categories
to help separate this up
into logical subsections.
To do this, we simply wrap
these preference objects
with a PreferenceCategory tag.
And as you can see, this
now adds an accented title
above these groups.
Again, it's important
to set a key for these,
so it would be considered a
correctly persisted state.
And the title again, same
as before, same attribute,
just displayed
slightly differently.
Next, we're going to add
an EditTextPreference,
similar to a
SwitchPreferenceCompat in that
it's a subset of a preference.
This preference uses
a dialogue to allow
persisting a string value.
So when the user taps
on this preference,
we automatically open
a dialogue for you,
which contains an
editable text field.
And when the user taps on OK,
this value is then persisted.
However, this gives us
some interesting questions.
What do we set for
the summary here?
Right now, there's no summary,
so it's quite hard for the user
to see what the
current state is.
And we would like to show the
user what they've actually
saved, so they know
what they've done.
But since this can change
dynamically at runtime,
we can't just put a string here.
The answer here is to use
a simple summary provider.
This is added recently
in the 1.1 Alpha release.
And it's part of a
broad category of things
we call Dynamic Summaries.
I'll cover more
about that later on.
But this simple attribute,
when set to true,
will mean that the preference
summary will automatically
display either the value saved
for the preference or the text
not set, if there
isn't any value set.
So now we have a way for
the user to set a sync code,
and they can see the value
they've set automatically.
However, there's
one problem here.
It doesn't really
make much sense
for the user to be able to
change this field if syncing
actually isn't enabled.
We can use a dependency
here to fix that.
Essentially,
setting a dependency
allows another
preference to control
the state of this preference.
So we set the key of the
SwitchPreferenceCompat
that will control
this preference.
So this means that whenever
the switch preference is turned
off, as it is here, the actual
preference is grayed out
and can no longer
be interacted with.
And when the switch
is turned on,
the preference returns to normal
and can be interacted with.
Our hierarchy is almost complete
from the example that we gave.
The only thing
we'd now like to do
is set a useful summary
for this switch.
Right now, Enable
Periodic Syncing
is on, but what does
that actually mean?
Have we synced recently?
Maybe there's a problem
connecting to the server.
So we can use a custom
dynamic summary here
to display to the user when
we've lost sync to providing
some more useful context.
In general, dynamic
summaries are
useful in two sort
of broad scenarios.
Firstly, if you'd like to
provide the user with more
context that is tied to
a specific preference,
and what it means.
So in this case, we'd
like to tell them when
we've last synced the device.
Or it can also be
useful if you'd
like to display some
dynamic information.
This could be something
like a version information
of your application or
even user information,
such as a specific
ID or email address.
To set this dynamic summary,
we use the SummaryProvider
interface.
We can use this to either
react to the internal state
of the preference or
just use it as a callback
to generate our own dynamic
summary from external state.
Here, we set the type as
SwitchPreferenceCompat.
That is, that is the
type of preference
that we're setting
the summary for.
When the preferences are
checked, in other words,
when syncing is enabled, we want
to just display that last time
we successfully synced.
And otherwise, we're
just going to say
it's disabled, so it's
clear to the user.
And this is all there
really is to it.
All we need to do now is just
set this on the Preference.
So to do that, we
call FindPreference
using the key we previously
assigned in the XML.
And then we just set
the summary provider.
This and any other
similar configuration
should be done in
onCreatePreferences
in your
PreferenceFragmentCompat.
And now, whenever I
use the toggles instead
of the preference, the
summary will automatically
be updated based on the
constraints we defined.
Now that we've built up a
more advanced hierarchy,
I'm going to cover using
separate hierarchies
in separate screens.
Oftentimes, you'll want to split
up more complex hierarchies
into separate
screens, making sure
that less important preferences
aren't cluttering up
your main screen and
making it hard for the user
to focus on the things they
actually want to change.
If you're already
using the Framework API
and looking to migrate,
there are some different ways
you may have structured
your separate screens.
And if you're starting out fresh
with the AndroidX Preference
library, you may be
wondering what the best
way of handling this is.
But first, let's just recap
how a single screen looks.
We have our activity at the
top, which will internally
wrap a fragment, which then
contains its actual hierarchy.
We can kind of
consider the fragment
in the hierarchy to be sort
of a screen of settings.
So in reality, we
just have an activity
which loads a setting
screen, which is this.
And this works fine
when we have one screen.
But what if our hierarchy
looked something like this?
Now on our first screen, we
have links to other screens.
So the sync will
link to a screen
of sync-related
preferences and Messages
will link to some more specific
messages-related preferences.
How does this look like
with our architecture?
It's actually very simple to
what we've done previously
with a single screen.
The Initial Settings
screen will just
be just as before-- a
PreferenceFragmentCompat
with a hierarchy.
And then the
Sync-Scanning screen
will also be a
PreferenceFragmentCompat
with its own hierarchy, and
so on for any other screens
you may have.
What we need to
do now differently
is just the final link between
the SyncPreference object
and the SyncSettings
fragment, so whenever
the user clicks on
this preference,
we will load the related screen.
So we'll start off in
this state, pointing
to the Initial Settings screen.
When the user taps
a preference, now
that we've already
defined this link,
we're just going to swap out
the screen from underneath.
And because we're still using
Preferences to act as the link,
the Initial Settings
hierarchy is
going to be just as
we've done before.
So again, we start with the
root PreferenceScreen tag,
and we just have two
basic preferences--
one for syncing and
one for messages.
It's important, while you
may want to add an icon here
to the start of the preference,
to provide some more context
to the user, as we don't really
have an important summary
display here.
This is just done by defining
a drawable with the Icon
attribute.
So this will just be something
in your res/drawable directory.
And now the only
thing left to do
is just to find the links
between the fragments.
So to do this, we use
the Fragment attribute,
and we just set the
fully-qualified class
name of the fragment.
If your fragment is
nested in a class,
you'll need to use
the dollar sign
to separate the outer
class and the inner class.
And that's it for the hierarchy.
The activity is very similar
to what we had before.
We just set the Initial
Settings screen to be displayed.
The only difference
here is that we
should implement this method,
onPreference.Fragment.
This method is called when a
user taps on a preference that
has an associated
fragment and allows
you to customize any
transitions or animations
between fragments.
There is a default
implementation.
So if you don't
overwrite this method,
we will still handle it for you.
But you won't have any nice
transitions or animations
that you may want.
And the fragments are going to
be exactly the same as before.
Again, all we need
to do here is just
overwrite onCreatePreferences
and set the relevant XML
resource.
And that's really it now.
Whenever a user taps on
the messages or the sync
preference, the
corresponding fragment
will be ultimately
displayed to the user.
So to wrap some things up, we've
recently released 1.1 Alpha01.
So please, if you
haven't already, get it.
Try using Dynamic Summaries
and other recent features.
Please forward any bugs
and feature requests
to this component on
issuetracker.google.com.
We've recently updated
the Android Settings
Guide to make use of the
AndroidX Preference library.
Please check it out
for further information
on some of the
things I've talked
about in this talk and
some other features out
of the scope of this talk.
And we're working on
Template for Android Studio,
as well as public
samples demonstrating
this new library coming soon.
For more information
on Android Jetpack,
you can go to
developer.android.com/jetpack.
And thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]